Brian.
You know,
as we have talked about this
every day, every step of the way
now you have the executive summary
the charges that they think
that they have sufficient eviden
Do you see clear evidence for th
to charge Trump
on the four referrals
that they are specifically makin
Absolutely.
And three of the four at least.
So obstruction
of congressional proceedings
including pressuring
Mike Pence, conspiracy
to defraud
the American public of a fair
and election,
false statements
and the full slate of electors.
And then there's this more troub
one of an insurrection,
which I think it's good
for the committee to have presen
But with the Justice Department
actually moving forward, it's
a pretty steep hill for them.
So you're not sure on that one,
but three of the four
and by the way,
to be clear,
one of those three alone
carries a 25 year possible sente
So we're talking
incredibly serious charges,
even if they don't
go with the insurrection.
Sir John,
the transcripts
you just heard the congresswoman
speak of that
she said there's going to be a l
We're going to find out.
Look, it's
going to be voluminous,
as I said,
but a lot is going to come out
and a lot of new details.
How important are those transcri
going to be
to the Department of Justice,
which, of course, has asked for
repeatedly over months
and they have been refused by
the committee,
but now they are going to get th
this week.
They could cut a number of ways.
First of all, it's
prior testimony they might confl
Some people said in
the grand jury is a problem
It also could open doors
they don't have open at this poi
and they'll take these people
into the grand jury
and get the testimony nailed dow
So I think they're a remarkable
and I'm sure the Justice Departm
is going to dove right in. Right
And it's really important that y
could there be contradictions
and that that that is,
you know, in a sense
maybe makes this longer or not s
So, Stephanie, we heard today
Trump was not going to watch
what happened today,
but you know him well.
And a big part of this actually
is how he was watching that day.
Every single thing and doing not
How much is he watching?
Literally and figuratively?
He's watching. He's absolutely w
I said earlier,
he may have gone to golf today
just to kind of put on a show
that he wasn't watching.
But I guarantee you
he was getting real time updates
And he's already
put a tweet out this evening
talking about it, talking some n
about double jeopardy
So he is very much
paying attention to this.
I know. He's got to be worried.
I'll be interested.
I have a feeling after
all of this has happened,
he's going to
go out and start
campaigning
because as you guys have noticed
he has not campaigned once
since he announced.
So I think he's going to start
to try to distract from this.
Right. Right.
And of course, as they point out
here, a big part of what he did
here was raise money off oh, yes
So I suppose we could see that a
So when I want to read something
from the committee summary repor
that was released today,
the committee has substantial co
regarding potential efforts
to obstruct its investigation,
including by certain counsel.
And then they say some paid
by groups
connected to the former presiden
who may have advised clients
to provide false
or misleading testimony to the c
I mean, they go into detail sayi
that that this counsel told a wi
to say she did not recall
when she did recall as just one
And you think this is significan
Yeah, I think it's highly signif
In fact,
when Jones
says handing the Justice Departm
a resource, this is a huge resou
it is a pool of people
who seem to have criminal liabil
for trying to lie to Congress
and in lawyers telling their cli
to lie.
It's essentially a lie to say,
I don't recall
when you do absolutely recall.
And that means that the special
can now
have this entire group of indivi
with their transcripts,
with the committee's evidence,
who he could try to flip.
He could say, you're exposed.
There's a great
deal of legal jeopardy for you.
So why don't you cooperate with
in my investigation,
looking at the actions
of President Trump,
tell me everything you know.
So it gives them more people to
if they need
if they're running up against wa
So one of the people that is nam
the whole point is
we were just talking about
with Congresswoman Murphy is Don
Trump and others.
Now, there's one other
who is named in to specific char
And that, of course, is John Eas
the attorney He said something t
He tried to pooh-pooh the whole
but he said something
that could be important.
John,
he said he has not received
a subpoena in the DOJ criminal p
so he hasn't been subpoenaed.
What does that say?
It could say he's going to
get a target letter soon.
They don't need him.
If they assume probably
if he comes into the grand jury,
he'll take the Fifth
and won't be a witness
in any circumstances.
So I think he knows well enough
the process
as a former law professor
at law school, dean,
what have you, how this works.
He shouldn't expect a subpoena u
the time is right and it's not r
Something as you read
through all this today,
it hit home, right,
because you knew
all the people you were there.
You you have answered questions
about this yourself to the commi
So the former president puts out
a statement tonight.
These folks don't get it.
Then when they come after me,
people who love freedom rally ar
It strengthens me.
What what do you make
of that as a response?
I mean, obviously could be, you
he puts on
whatever kind of facade
he wants to put on,
but this is where he is.
Yeah.
I mean, this is
this is part him,
you know, bloviating that
everything will be fine.
It kind of struck me a little bi
like with the rally,
like he's
like getting his people amped up
they're going to support me.
These people will never leave me
But I think that
what I want the viewers to know
and just having known him for so
take a step back,
he's just trying to distract peo
The point is, today we made hist
I mean, this was a horrible day,
by the way, a horrible day for u
But they
the former president
got referred to the DOJ,
and that's
what he's trying to distract peo
So I think people need to really
remember that.
And, you know,
all of these investigations
that are going on right now,
I can't keep track of them and I
just in half of them.
That's not like that's not he's
But it's a witch hunt.
It's not that everyone's after h
Like, people need to realize
this is a real, real serious pat
And what is the bottom line
in terms of what you think
this does for the DOJ?
You heard Rod Rosenstein earlier
he doesn't think this will impac
but what does it mean for the ti
of a DOJ indictment decision?
Well, I do think that it changes
public opinion
as long as the public digest
the general lesson
that's been given to us today.
And the DOJ is not ignorant of t
So I do think for them to unders
that the public sees
these major breaches of law
and that they are criminal
does put added pressure
on the DOJ to act fast.
And we've got the person in that
who will act fast which is Jack
Jack Smith, the special counsel.
Thank you all very much.